[Music]
all right hello everyone this is grand
master alexander landerman um
this is gonna be my
last video for the time beating since
today is my last day as german residents
so hopefully it's
going to be a good one about the end
games so
today was uh today's supposed to be the
end the one about queen and games but
uh we'll do this one rook end game
because i
wanted to show it in the earlier videos
on technique and
and or how to convert winning positions
and or rook end games but i kind of
forgot to put it in so i'll just show
this one example and then i'll the rest
of them will be queen end games so
um
so this is actually my u.s championship
game against
a wonder liang
and i was black in the game i'm up two
points should be easily winning but i
misplayed it and i even made a draw
so the question is what do you think is
the simplest winning plan for black here
well if yeah if you can if you can trade
all rooks then that should be easily
winning but that will not be
so easy
um
b1 um yeah that was the correct move
rook b1 because after rook b1
white uh cannot play b3 because there
would be two
if you go king f3 take take rook b2 and
then rook b5 and i'm going to be up
three pawns and it's easy
and uh
if rook takes g5 i i undouble my pawns
and now i have three connected past
pawns like this
and even though i'm giving up a pawn
after b3 i'm gonna lose the a5 pawn this
is still very easily winning
my pawns are going to be pushing and
it's a very simple win
so yeah this was pretty much uh
completely game over
but instead i kind of got careless i i
think i relaxed too early
um and i thought this wins as well rook
c1 but after rook c1
king f3
it was already not so easy
like i ended up playing rook cc5 but
yeah this is already kind of
a bit more difficult he's able to keep
all the rooks and uh
you know there's more to this end game
than just that one moment it's a certain
endgame you can study it's in the
database but
you know that was uh
that was another moment when even if
you're completely winning you never want
to have this
lapse of concentration when you see a
good move you try to look for
a better move try to look at the forcing
moves
yeah i can do that but then i can play
here and then after this i can play rook
a5
and this is not
entirely that easy
like i can even have a better version i
can play rook f1 check
king 2 rook takes g2
king takes rook takes rook a5
and my king is cut off and i thought
this is maybe winning but
um but yeah then
still i thought with these pawns the
problem is if i exchange my f pawn for
the a pawn it will probably be a draw in
most cases because it's f and h points
could still it's still very often i draw
so this is kind of still
this has technical difficulties
um okay so now we move on to the main
topic of the lesson it's about queen end
games
um i want to start off with a game i
played um
against hans neiman last year at the
at the spice cup uh which was actually
one of the few tournaments over the
board that
uh didn't get cancelled um
yeah it was a very strong term i played
hans neiman at that time he was low
rated 24.65
but now he's something like 26 50 feet
day
uh back then he was 24 so he made a huge
run uh of about almost 200 points within
a
within a year basically
yeah this was the opening battle will
kind of skip through
and we're going to start off with when
the
i guess from um
from around let's see
um
yeah from this position so
so what do you guys how do you think you
would uh react to this move a4 here so
white played a4 trying to
question what i'm gonna do with the
spawn on b5 what would you do about it
what do you think
you said b4 and then try to play five
okay
um
possible
any other suggestions
let's see what people on youtube have in
mind
okay
um
well actually the thing is i think b
takes a4 is more george because before
i'm actually trying to keep some points
on the board right so maybe if anything
before i'm trying to play for
for a win actually before is what i
played but it turned out to be a mistake
because i'm putting my pawns on the
color of this bishop i'm restricting
this bishop and i'm allowing this idea
knight d5
after which he gets a lot of initiative
the thing is if he would have played
knight d5 immediately
i could take
and then you go i go queen g1 and then
he kind of needs to go back to d1
but uh after playing a4 first
now the problem is
if i give this check from g1 he goes
king a2 the king actually on a2 is
extremely safe like it seems like it's
under risk but actually it's my king
that's under danger because white's
pieces
are putting a lot of pressure on it
so there could be some serious problems
from my king here
so the better move would be ba
which would not allow him to play knight
d5 and then
you know this would be kind of equal
but i played this as a big mistake
and he could have punished me for this
so here i played queen c8 my best move
because after this and king here like i
already mentioned this is very difficult
for me
so i played queen c8
and here he could have played king a2
simple prophylactic move just stopping
all my play
let's say queen e6 rook d7 and
even this end game is horrible for me
because all my pawns are weak and his
rook is rook is more active than mine
and his knight is more active than my
bishop
and the pawns are weak so this is pretty
much lost
so if he plays king a2 it's uh pretty
much a lost position like material is
equal but his pieces are just way better
than mine
instead he played rook g7 a more forcing
move
i played queen e8 like kind of my only
move to try to keep things together
no here at actually at this point i
would have been very happy with the draw
in this position like
even against player much lower rated so
um
servo k7
bishop f6 at least i'm getting a little
bit of counter play here he played
knight d7 and here i found the pretty
nice idea does anyone want to see if
they can find it
what should block do here
well maybe
so if we play queen f2 i can play
probably knight f6 and then rook a6 at
the very least and then i'm going to be
up opponent
very very happy
maybe even rook a6 immediately
bishop d4
i think also does not do much i can play
rook a6 it doesn't really have a threat
i can even play rook c7 and then after
rook moves
i can play knight e5 and queen f7
something like that
so
black has to play very precisely he has
only one move to not not lose pretty
much
rook c8 loses because of knight f6 pawn
takes queen f7
so bishop c3 i don't think is that good
because knight f8
and i don't think i don't see the next
move here
uh queen e6 will lose because then night
at night knight f8
queen e6 knight of eight is easily
bishop g4
i think we can play like i said rook a6
or c7
and then if the rook moves we can play
95 and we're winning
also try to give
don't just give one move try to give a
variation
yeah try to give a variation don't just
say one movement
okay from now on i'm not gonna accept
one move solutions
you know you guys gotta try to work
harder let's not be lazy here
because yeah the problem with one move
solutions that means you're not really
considering card
considering very seriously opponents
replies so you have to make sure you
always try to consider opponents replies
unless your move is like made in one
you know you shouldn't give one more
solutions
okay queen e7 knight of six knight queen
seven knight d6 queen f6 okay that's in
27 is maybe an interesting defensive
move but
i think after queen d5 our position is
still very bad
like it's still very very difficult to
defend here
i mean i'm threatening rook a6
rook d8 i guess
i can play
rook a8
still feels very
very difficult here because of queen d7
queen d7
and then rook is pinned
okay queen e7 is probably the second
best move to
you know if you don't find the defense
probably queen e7 is relatively best
okay so avinash you got the right move
but make sure you give the variation
like explain the move
because this is something that okay
all right very good so patrick got it
yes so bishop xb2 is the okay now people
are getting bishop xb2 is very important
if king b2 queen f2 we have and we pick
up the rook on a7
and if queen takes
b2 and if queen takes bits we have b3
check
and that disturbs his harmony so
the point is after this again we have
queen f2 check
and material will be equal
and um if king a3
we can play queen e7 king there and then
queen e3
so
so king takes b3 queen e3 check
and here we got this end game queen a7
knight f8 and
here i got a little bit careless
actually
although that was maybe a blessing in
disguise because i ended up winning the
game
uh somehow you know we'll see how but i
should have played queen b7
and only after this queen is seven and
uh
and the point is he can keep the knight
but then um
we have some perpetual ideas and uh yeah
this is uh
this is a draw
instead i thought king takes f8 is uh is
a pretty easy draw
but i missed my opponent's um
winning tries so let's start with now
this queen end game from this position
so
this was very interesting so first of
all how would you try to
play for a win here like let's try to
find like a winning attempt for white
which
really puts me on the back foot
unfortunately i missed my opponents
very strong winning attempt here
yeah this is not easy but
um
let's see if you can find what hans did
here
threaten mate okay so how exactly you
throw one threat mate
okay queen g3 you can play but i think i
can play queen b6 check and then
uh yeah it's a threat but it doesn't
really
it's not so lethal because we can defend
pretty easily and then we can play g6
and yeah that should be a
handshaking pretty soon draw
so
so queen e5 and queen d4 so queen e5
i think we can give the check still
maybe
what's the
oh okay you thought 25 was check i see
yeah white found a very nice unique idea
all right queen c6 is an interesting try
a queen c6 though i can go queen e3
check
and i'm going to get a lot of counter
play on your pawns
so i wasn't that afraid of that move i
thought
it's it's risky
queen d2 i guess i can play something
like
maybe even king e7 it
should be good enough after that
yeah because i cannot give a check here
because of queen before that pawn end
game is losing so we have to be careful
but you know i can play king e7
which pawn on game um
no no four for black of course
yeah for black
so queen c8 is is correct
and then after king is seven what's the
what's the
move
we want to try to threaten setting up a
pawn man game
yes very good that's the key move and
suddenly queen c5 is a really big lethal
threat
and here i suddenly thought
my gosh i'm losing this
but
somehow somehow i managed to find
i managed to regain my composure here
and find
the best move for block
the only idea that makes a draw like it
was a miracle that i even had it like i
did not see it ahead of time it seems
like i always get lucky against hans
neiman because my last two over the
board games i played against him
i did not see the you know the correct
move from far away but somehow it always
was there for me when i need it you know
there's always some important ideas
somewhere
so i feel like in that sense i've been
getting quite lucky against him
recent games but
anyway
you know now that we have this position
what would you do
um okay so king d6 i think actually does
not quite i mean i guess it's uh
if you feel like you're losing that's
probably the best chance but the problem
is queen f8
thought that's that my chances of
surviving this are pretty slim
like i'm gonna lose at least the pawn
here and uh
king c6 i thought you could take this
guy
and i did not think i have perpetual
because
queen blocks i thought
i mean i'm not sure i don't maybe that
was a
yeah i thought i thought i thought it
loses king d6
um yeah queen d7 i'm pretty sure this
i can go even queen a6 if i want
um and that's a one down end game
but i might be able to win with uh takes
and
king c5 and uh a5
not sure though
maybe i have to play a more accurate
move here but i think this this one
might be losing
um
because his king is more active
so there's actually only one way i can
get into poking and pointing and that's
actually not losing
it's a
pretty
crazy idea and that was i it was it was
kind of i thought it was my only move
and
af5 i don't think
helps i mean like at the very least i
can take this pawn right
um
queen b6 then queen c5
and then he takes my pawn
yeah i mean okay this is a very hard one
so i guess i'll show it to you but it's
a very nice concept
i played h5
okay that move looks completely crazy
because
i'm basically allowing queen c5 check
right
now white had other moves but they don't
really lead too much
but i thought queen c5 is
but then
the thing is i go g6 and
the big the big idea i saw here is that
i have i still have two spare tempos f6
and f5
and the thing is when he goes ahead and
uh
goes after my pawn with king b6
okay i think somebody just asked the
question what if i do queen d6 which
which line is this oh okay it's oh oh i
see what you're saying here on queen d6
uh-huh
yeah then i think uh i can go king b4
and then uh i can threaten to take on
king i5 yeah i'm pretty sure it wasn't
working i checked this yesterday with
the engine again and basically h5 was
the only move that was not losing so you
can check it for yourself as well but
yeah it was actually the only move that
wasn't losing
like it was a miracle that i had this
move like i could have easily not had it
and i would have lost
but yeah it was
so yeah queen c5 he played takes takes
on g6 and the thing about this g6 move
very strong move
is that i fixed his pawns he can't go f5
he can't do anything there and if he
tries to go king b6 i go here then i go
king c6 and actually his king is cut off
and it seems like he should still win
with the move a5
like if because of here then king c5
right
so it seems like he should still win
because of a5
but then i can play let's move f6
and i still have a spare tempo and then
after this i can go king c7
and then the reason i played f6 is so
that after a6
now i play a five and i have that second
spare temple
and then i can make
the draw
king here king c8
here king c7 it's a draw actually no
here i'm winning
maybe yes so he has to be careful you
know and go back king a7
but and if he tries f5 here
what move do i play here for black
what's the what's my drawing idea
f4
yes f4 takes and then
yes very good
and this is a draw
quite incredibly
so this was this was truly a miracle
that somehow you know i was just in time
to make this draw
um and he cannot do anything about it
his king gets stuck and i have two spare
temples that's
really important okay f5 does not really
help because i take
and again it's the same thing here i
play f6
and i always have this f4 idea
it's going to be the same thing
yeah anyway so this was very very
interesting um
so my opponent hans tried king d5 he
tried to trick me in some other ways
but then i played the king f6
because i realized that he goes back i
go back again so i'm not worried about
losing the a6 pawn now
once i found this setup
so he played the king c6 i played king
e6
what's happening
wait okay yeah king is six king c5 he's
trying to somehow
outflank me but i played king e7 because
i guess i thought if king here king d5
he's getting something with that
position like i saw some line like here
and then he blows f5
and after this king f5 so this was his
other idea he wanted to play this
and then after this
he wanted to play g4 and make an outside
passport potentially
or maybe a5 i don't remember what
exactly it was but
this i thought was a bit dangerous
but i played king e7 so like again if
this i can always go here
and if this i go here so i'm not letting
him you know get any kind of winning
ideas here
so i had to be still very precise but at
this point i was already optimistic that
i'm drawing
so he played there i played here
he played king d6 i played king f5
he tried a5 and now i played f6
and the thing is um
and what happened here was something
very unfortunate i wish i didn't really
wanna of course i don't really like to
win like this um
basically my opponent was getting low on
time and he kept desperately looking he
kept desperately looking for a win
but it was not there unfortunately for
him and so he couldn't find it and uh
basically he forgot about his clock he
lost on time
so it's very painful of course at this
point it should have been a draw and
that would have been a fair result so it
was very it was a kind of a big pity
because um
he was he was on a very good run and
then he lost his game and then he had a
bad tournament kind of because of this
game
uh but i was very happy that you know
after this tournament where you know he
lost such a painful game he made such a
recovery and then he went to europe and
he made a
uh a norm his last norm right after that
and he got 2500 and
you know ever since he's been on a tear
he's won numerous tournaments he
won the u.s junior he got to over well
over 2600 so
i mean it was uh a lot of kudos to him
after such a painful game such a painful
tournament to
to be able to recover
i don't exactly know it could 19 or 20
or something like that
so he's under 21 i think he's definitely
under 21. i think it's either 19 or 20.
i don't know exactly but
yeah so that was an interesting game um
you know where uh most tournaments did
not happen well this one did and
brought this exciting game
um
but unfortunately i also did not have a
good tournament i lost the very next
game after that so somehow this lucky
win did not bring me luck after that
um
but okay
what to do
um
yeah so this game is actually
uh let me just
maybe i think i'll skip this game one
second
yeah um let me think
okay this is a this is a oh actually
hans is only 18.
um
okay this is a little bit of an endgame
study with queens on the board so let's
see how you guys do with this one
why to play and win
obviously if he wants to make a draw he
can do it in many different ways
well i mean okay it's uh i mean i was i
was upset when i lost the fabian caruana
right like i think you know we're
competitors right the way
i mean
an anime makes sense he's upset like and
now he's higher rated than me
so you know he
he probably did not really consider me a
strong gm so
at that time
um
so no i think you can't really respect
any player too much because um
you know then you're limiting yourself
to reaching your your potential and it's
it's also not just about losing but it's
also about how you lose right okay if
you get upset you know
you you know if you get out played then
okay you shouldn't necessarily get upset
but i mean it's not doesn't matter
against whom right you you can get up
you know you can get out played by a
lower rated then but if they play an
amazing game i mean kudos to them
right but if it's uh unnecessary loss
that's what you're upset about typically
um
all right so g7 is correct queen takes
yeah and then we have to find the
the mating sequence here
mating or we're winning some material
yes exactly dania daniel nardinski beat
fabi even though
uh daniel you know did not have the best
tournament he
he lost a lot of games also but you know
against fabi he played a really nice
game especially the techniques so
you know yeah you have to believe you
can win and
otherwise there's no point of even
sitting across the board
uh playing
okay you will you might not always get a
chance to win but
you have to always believe
queen b8 queen e7 i oh queenie king is
seven you man okay
queen d8
king is six
okay let's continue
this is correct
yeah queen d7 king of six
yeah queen d4 king here
yes very good and then queen edge
formate
very nice
very nice for sequence
yeah
okay
all right so here's another
interesting exercise
um black to play what should black do
here
okay let's not say kill porn right we're
serious chess players here you can say
capture or
you know
we're serious players here so let's
not be silly
yes exactly yeah h6 was a pretty serious
threat
all right people on youtube looks like
are
getting the right idea
so if we play if we attack the rook we
have to ask ourselves can white still
play h6 right because as sam shankland
always says in his videos in his
lectures
he says um
when um
when we have a very dangerous idea and
you think that opponent stops us we have
to ask ourselves can we still do it
anyway
that's something he always talks about
in all his videos
so that's something we have to always
keep in mind so
if you think you're playing queen e2 to
stop h6 you have to ask yourself are you
actually stopping h6 can you still do it
anyway
so that's the that's the question
so that's something you got to calculate
queen e2 is certainly a very tempting
move or queen c2 or any of these moves
but
but what happens after h6 can he get
away with h6 and
giving you the rook with chuck or no
so yes g3 is the is a very strong move
here and i think uh people on youtube
are also getting it the problem is if
you play a move like
obviously g takes is losing because
takes takes and then rook comes in rook
lift
i mean wins okay maybe not to rely right
away but you have to do it in the
correct way
and if you play
queen in c2 or queen e2
after h6 takes the problem is that there
is king h2
and only after this king g2 and now
there is no more queen of three check
right so very precise calculation is
required now
we simply lose this it will get made it
so we play g3 disturbing is harmony
we're trying to take on f2 trying to
exchange queens because the queen on f6
is very important
and after this we can play
queen e2 or queen b3 and now
after this i'm sorry h6
we can take and go queen d2 queen h6
and we are winning the game
so yes g3 is the correct idea
okay here's another exercise
uh black to play
uh yeah here we're fighting to make a
draw because white has a very
uh
menacing one on c6
how should we do it
we have several options
yes ff4 definitely is a move we have to
consider
um yeah and then there's also maybe
other moves too but
yeah we definitely have to consider f4
and
and see if
but now you know you have to analyze
what will happen after f4 right so don't
just stop there don't just give me one
more solutions that's a lazy approach to
chess
uh let's try to analyze
you know whether or not
white can then do something which
could try to play for a win
all right queen b6 will also take a look
at that
um don't think that will save us but
um okay we'll
look at that next
no of course i understand i understand
the point of f4 of course if they go c7
we give perpetual but the question is
does white have anything better yes
exactly uh f4 we can play queen e5
and after king h7 or something or king
somewhere the problem is you can now go
c7 and then
and then you've defended the e1 square
right so this this will not be perpetual
anymore that's the big problem
so yeah he can include queen e5 right
and he and you don't have perpetuals so
f4 unfortunately
does not work
it will lose
queen b6
also loses i think because queen e5
check
let's say king g8
and now we can play c7 and queen e is a
threat
we also have queen c3 idea
so we will lose this pretty easily
so black needs to do something else here
i see it's okay
it's okay but let's try to understand
why the why that's the answer
okay queen e3 that's that move is also
interesting i guess thinking after c7 f4
that's actually pretty clever
unfortunately it doesn't quite work
because i can go queen g3 queen c3 very
strong maneuver
and then that's still winning for white
so it's a very clever try hoping for c7
f4 but it doesn't
it doesn't quite draw
hey
queen takes b2 is the yes the correct
move
and the point of queen b2 is not so much
because we want the pawn it's more to
control
this very important square c3 which
white very often controls and also
control e5 so the key is we're
controlling all these dark squares and
we're controlling the pawn
and now the problem is white cannot make
any progress
because in order in order for him to win
the game he needs to promote the pawn
but if he plays something like queen d7
queen d8 we start checking him
and this will be perpetual on the e1
square
so queen takes b2
is a very strong
very strong move
so yeah sometimes these queen end games
are a little bit counter-intuitive you
have to just calculate and the
ultimately it's about process of
elimination sometimes also because once
you see a four you see all your
opponent's ideas like 25
and uh yeah queen g3 all these queen c3
ideas then you can figure out that maybe
i should take the spawn
it's not easy but again you guys are all
good players so i'm trying to do some
challenging
ones for you
okay let's look at um
another one
okay this is actually from
yeah this is a game from
my students
the player playing white is the player
playing black is my student and i gave
the ratings but
i kept the names
away because of uh
yeah the thing is it's not about the
pawn on b2 right it's more about the
the c3 square right it's it's it's more
about uh and e5 square right so it's the
pawn is meaningless you're right but
it's more about other things
all right so here we have a interesting
position okay so this is a
okay this is an interesting position
here um
so
black has a dilemma of where to move the
queen
it has several options
where should black move the queen here
and why
oh what do you think
i think he's probably happy with
equality here right because white seems
to he can win a lot of pawns so
i think that um
we're pretty probably going to be happy
with the draw here although if we find
something better than you know
more power to you
sir
sure yeah but i think this this one is
not that great because
take take rook b7 i mean you're gonna
lose a pawn and now this is weak
and if you go rookie eight i can go king
of two so that doesn't seem
that doesn't seem very
very good
so yeah we have i think queen d5 we
don't we don't want to play here
so the real question is
uh we need to somehow create counterplay
towards the skink and use the spawn on
h3 as some kind of attacker
but the question is
do we go queen h5 queen g4 queen of five
like which one of these moves
make sure you give explanation that
don't just give don't just give a move
maybe give a variation and or
explanation
okay so we have to kind of compare queen
of five and queen g queen queen h5 right
so
so in the game
black played two h5 queen f5 is indeed
the best move
um
and the main reason why queen f5 is the
best move is because after queen takes
b7
rook g8
queen takes c6 white is going to try to
take all these pawns and cover the g2
square but the difference now is we can
go
queen b1 check
and queen takes b2
uh and we won't win these important
points so white plays rookie two
but now we play queen c1 and by winning
that b2 pawn now we opened up our b file
for rb8 rook b1
in order for us to create you know
sufficient counter play
so this is actually very important a
very important idea
the problem is when we go queen h5 or
queen g4
after white does the same thing
now queen d1 doesn't do very much
because king of two
quincy two rookie two and white keeps
this very important pawn so the point is
we needed to check on b1 to take on b2
and then play rook b8 right that of one
pawn was a big very big difference
so when you compare these variations
this is a big improvement
um
for white and now white is winning here
um
so black tried rook b8 anyway
b3 or queen g4
queen c7
yeah care king of two was um possible
queen c7
rook g8
king f2
queen f5
rookie one
queen c2
a hero c8 actually was
was fine
uh so black missed that queen c2 here
queen c1 queen d7 f5
white should be winning here
too many extra pawns
but white actually made a mistake uh
here so what here the question is
i mean this position looks completely
winning
uh but
how should we
what's the best way to try to convert
this still not entirely easy even though
we're up um
two three four five even though we have
two pawns
it's still not that easy because black
gets queen h1 counter plays so we need
to try to
play precisely find the winning plan
so black's idea is queen h1 right so we
have to make sure we
were prepared for him playing queen h1
alright so queen of three is what white
is what white played but then what do
you do after queen d4 check
well queen e3 i'm going to go back right
it's just the repetition where our queen
was on e3 so if you're going to go like
this
we're just repeating moves right
so
queen g4 king f1 queen of queen of wanna
go queen d1 check and now you have to go
back because rookie one or queen f3
so it's not easy rookie three was played
in the game but that's not so good after
rookie eight suddenly we're in that pin
and then it became very difficult to win
maybe not even winning
so you have to be you know
you have to kind of be
be careful here
all right looks like hamilton got the
right idea we play the move g4 here a
double exclamation mark
and the point is we free the g3 score
for the king where the king is safe and
the point is after this we have king g3
and white is winning
and after fg we have king g3
and then we take on g4 and
and white is
white is winning
um
oh yeah king g3 is probably the simplest
just pick up all the pawns and then
black's king becomes weakened yeah this
would have been
simple win but g4 is not an easy move to
find
but yeah sometimes in queen endgames you
have to always look at
you know unusual ideas
why not queen d6 before g4
queen d6 i mean queen d3
i guess you meant queen d3 but then i
can play queen h oh queen e6 queen e6 um
i don't know maybe i can play rook h8
and after g4 maybe i can go queen h1
yeah i don't know maybe this also wins
but i think it's unnecessary i think g4
and then king king here is easier
because the queen is very good here it
protects a lot a lot of
weak squares so i really don't think we
need queen e6 here
although maybe the other one also wins
but also we have to worry about queen d4
here you know
it's possible i just think g4 is simpler
because black cannot do much
because we're not worried about the
spawn really that much
i'm going to take it probably next move
actually
so yeah in the game white played this
rookie 3 rookie 8
queen itsuruki3
and this endgame turned out to be
to be a draw
like white cannot make progress
surprisingly up two points it looks
winning but
the queen of three was a very strong
move threatening queen h1 and that pawn
on h
h3 is still a very big nuisance
white was still trying to win even here
but yeah actually he's now in danger of
losing it it became a two queen end game
for queen end game i meant to say
pretty exciting stuff
yeah and and in the four queen end game
black still had a winning chance with g5
but
black played this and blundered into a
perpetual
and finally the game ended in a draw
so exciting exciting battle there
between two young players
all right now i want to show a game
of mvl mvl against dingleran and
i wanna
you know
see if you guys could play better than
dink here
so where was the possession see this was
good
yeah maybe black could have played
better earlier but it was still winning
yeah and this was the critical moment um
so
should black um
i guess our choices are do we take on g6
do we play a five or do we play c2
which which one do we play and why
we have to calculate we have to make
sure we play
the right one here
dingleran who is great and this was a
classical game too he chose the wrong
one and lost
i sorry drew drew the game sir didn't
lose but
still
was winning so
um
so i'll give you guys a few minutes to
think on this one
f5 is f5 is logical in some ways but the
problem is it's also illogical because
we're leaving him with this very
dangerous pawn
so after a five we can play
something like queen f4
and after c2 we play g7 for example and
i don't know
you can't quite queen your pawn and uh
what are you going to do with the g pawn
that's still a very big nuisance
so i'm not so sure
so in the game black actually did play
c2 and it looks completely winning for
black because
it seems like white needs to
uh
you know take or but white actually can
get away with
the thing is white
white could get away with playing
g7
no sorry what happened in the game
yeah g7 actually would lose but white
can get away with gf and the thing about
this is that
if queen of seven this is already uh
a perpetual
uh
if you queen
somehow this four queen end game
even though it looks completely
winning for black because black is the
one started checks
somehow amazingly
enough uh
despite this attack
the white queens just control all the
squares and there's no mate right so
this is one of these where
it feels like there's some house should
be a win but but there is not
it's just incredible right so this is
just one of the more beautiful
examples
uh
and they yeah they agreed to draw there
was no
i mean the queens somehow protect each
other
in
in the most improbable way that there is
no
i mean there were traps in the middle of
the way but
there was just nothing to be done it was
it was a draw
like the engine just always showed draw
so it's pretty incredible
um
so i guess i think uh dingle ren just
didn't realize that you can
play like this and it's still a draw
like he's i guess he thought c2 is very
easily winning
but the thing is um
he could play this and i think this is
um
this is very simple and um
the thing to keep in mind in queen end
games is the importance of centralized
queen i hear the queen is centralized
and because of that
it shields from a lot of checks
and the white pawn is still very far
away so we got rid of the main counter
plate meanwhile the c3 pawn is still
lethal black is has the set of king c1
that means sorry b c2 king b2
and white kind of you know does not
really cannot really do very much
against this queen on d5
and and so this position is is winning
but again i mean i guess you know it's a
tricky situation because like
even though
you think this is winning it's going to
take a long time maybe and then the
other position i guess you think that he
cannot just make a queen like that
because
yeah two queens will mate but you know
you cannot take anything for granted
right
and uh when you're not 100 sure it's
better to play kind of something that's
more
kind of more of a guarantee because here
at least you know white cannot do
anything with the spawn and then
yeah kingdom 2 c2 this setup should be
a fairly easy win but this just goes to
show that even not it's not easy always
for top gm's
especially in time pressure
and now i want to end this lesson with
like
a very unfortunate
um
moment in my chess career which
maybe was a blessing in disguise because
i had a very bad tournament that
tournament but didn't set me up to have
a lower rate again and then i played the
world cup that same year one month later
and i beat the higher rated player
paiva lilyanov
and maybe if i would have had a higher
rating i would have played someone lower
maybe i would have lost
you never know um it was a little bit
strange
but anyway
things happen always for a reason and in
this tournament
and i started it was canadian open 2017
i started two out of two i was doing
very well this game against an im who i
think is now a gm
khc young
and uh you know things were going pretty
well i outplayed him in a very nice game
and eventually we got
we got a queen end game
yeah it was also a nice calculation at
some point on my part like
it was this
d3
yeah his only move was knight c4 to not
lose immediately because otherwise i go
d2 d3 g
then he played this and then i found
this nice idea 93 queen c2
he queen i played queen c2 and now
what is his only way not to lose
immediately
what is his way not to lose immediately
to keep the game going
well queen g3 is losing because it's
very easy because i go check i take and
then i go d2 with that that's very easy
for black
that's not really um
we have something that's giving giving
us a better chance it's still lost but
it's not
not immediately losing
no queen g2 is made threat right
and a queen b2 does not help we take
that so queen b2 we cannot play
so there's only one way to continue the
game here which
queen h8 well you're close yeah you have
to give up the queen the problem is i
take
and here you're still in that same
dilemma yes queen takes g6 you have to
at least open up my king
and then you give this check on e8 and
then you take the knight and the
difference is that
the of course i would have loved to go
king h7 and hopefully he takes the
knight and then i play d2 and win
immediately sadly for me queen e4 check
happens and then i cannot get out of
checks and it's a draw
so unfortunately i had to play king f6
and then he keeps checking me
he keeps checking me and then once my
king is on b3 and the worst square then
he takes the knight and then my pawn is
spinned now the thing is this position
is still completely winning and at this
point i had like
around close to an hour and he had the
increment basically 30 seconds a move he
had like a minute or two
yeah and here i did not show the best
technique i've i should probably start
with queen c3 king c2 that would have
been
by far the the simplest queen e4 king b2
checking c1 and that should be pretty
routinely winning somehow i overthought
this
i tried queen c7 gaining a tempo with
the check
and then i played here but
i guess i underestimated he can pin my
opponent
somehow it's still not easy so i kind of
thought i'm gaining a tempo but actually
i'm not because this king wants to go to
g1 and f2 anyway
now i played queen c3 king f1
i played g5 probably a useless move also
h4
i was kind of having a hard time finding
a plan here
king b2
queen d5 king c2 queen of five
queen c4
so i want to play king c1 and then d2
but he goes king here and now if i go
here he takes
still not easy so i played back
so yeah i was i was having a hard time
finding a plan
i played king d1 king c1 is probably
still better and
you know playing this probably still
winning
because the
in the queen end game the most important
is the quality of the pawns over
quantity
very often but yeah
uh king d1 queen e4 and uh
and here is my infamous uh moment of my
chess career i don't think
i mean there's a couple of other people
gm who's done that but you know that was
a very that was one of my most
embarrassing moments but you know it
just goes to show what happens to
absolutely everyone
here i
think i was planning to play d2 but then
the problem is there's queen here
queen c1 and now he has a very strong
move to make a draw does anyone
try to see if they can find it
white to play and make a draw
how does white make a draw here
yeah there's a way to make a draw for
sure
queen a2 is correct because that
threatens queen a4 and then queen a1 and
then
here i don't i cannot get out of checks
every other move still gives me chances
queen d3 for example queen c2
queen e4 queen c2 but because but after
queen a2 queen c2 does not help because
they're still
checks
so queen a2 is the key move
so anyway i was calculating some lines i
couldn't find anything you know i should
have played something like king c1
but you know i thought i'll be clever
i'll play queen c2 then i'll try to play
d2
and then i'll go king c1 and as soon as
i played queen c2 i unfortunately let go
and then to my horror
i
and in total shock i realized that i
self-made it myself
queenie won and i
i don't i think i just
was so shocked i didn't even let him
play the move i just kind of
sat there in shock and kind of just
resigned or something like it
obviously he was
seeing it
so yes
that was uh it just goes to show that
yeah if you ever have uh the reason i
brought it up is like it just goes to
show queen and games could be very
humbling that's
queen and games can sometimes make the
best of all of us right so it's uh
they're probably one of the most
challenging end games that exist because
they involve a lot of calculation and
a lot of care
and uh yeah you can never relax in queen
end games there can always be surprises
so um
yeah and hopefully if you have a bad
moment like that you just remember that
even even gm's have these moments too
so yeah i hope you enjoyed this this
class today and
and i'll see you guys well actually it's
my last class with you guys it's my last
day today with gm in residence but i
really enjoyed working with all of you
and hopefully you
you all enjoy
your next gm
um
all right take care
[Music]
you